what is this reality all about like what
are we what do you think we're here for
you're coming you're coming in hot with
the easy questions right
the podcast is called pretty intense
this qualifies as a pretty intense
question I I guess I would say we're
here to
have experiences grow from those
experiences and then figure out how to
contribute to a better world
by virtue of what we've learned as a
result of those experiences and the
growth that we've encountered as a
result of that yeah I mean growing is
fundamental to me as well
um what do you think do you think that
it's easier or harder in the world right
now like there just seems to be a I mean
the world in the last couple of years
has just been so interesting and
different and at times it feels like
timelines are so fast and I don't know
how spiritual you get or anything but it
just um it's a seems like a different
reality we continue to evolve into and
so
um you know
do you think it's easier or harder than
ever do you think there is more good
than ever or more bad than ever I think
it's a I think it's a little bit of both
I I would I would say that things are
pretty intense right now for everybody
right it is very intense out there
Everything feels intense
um Everything feels heavy uh and it's
it's an interesting time because we have
access free access to so many tools
to help us become better happier more
fulfilled Etc but we also have a culture
that
um
I think in certain ways coddles us and
tells us that the recipe for happiness
is comfort and luxury and material
accumulation and so it's never been
easier to be kind of sedentary right and
with the sedentary nature of our lives
and the easy access through Postmates
and delivery you know
services to have our food you know sent
directly to us like we don't have to do
very much right it's kind of the lap of
luxury and we want it yeah and we've and
we've deluded ourselves into thinking
this will make us happy but I think this
is moving us further and further apart
from happiness because happiness is a
function of of
feeling alive and in order to feel alive
we have to endure ourselves to putting
ourselves in in in challenging
circumstances to get out of our comfort
zone and try new things and you know our
culture doesn't necessarily drive us in
that direction which means we have to
take responsibility for that ourselves
it's insane to me that you know we live
in a nation that is so unbelievably
prosperous and yet we've never been more
unhealthy as a society obesity rates
type 2 diabetes heart disease these
conditions which are lifestyle chronic
lifestyle ailments a result of the way
the choices that we make about how we
live and what we eat and how we move our
bodies are unnecessarily debilitating
and killing millions and millions of
people every year meanwhile are rates of
of
depression anxiety all of these mental
disorders are higher than they ever have
been we're medicating people we're
feeding ourselves terrible processed
foods and we're sitting on our couch and
we have an endless stream of choices to
make about entertainment to distract us
from our reality or whatever it is that
you know we're uncomfortable with in our
lives and so we're in this mild
medicated State at all times whenever
we're bored we can just pick this thing
up and and scroll through it and so I
think we're detached and distanced in a
way that we never have been historically
from what makes us human which is
community and analog experiences and
moving our bodies and living uh more in
sync with the natural rhythms of the
planet all of these you know kind of
historical Primal ways of being that are
built into our DNA and our instinctual
our anathema to the modern way of life
and you know
so it's so it creates it creates this
dissonance I think because like I said
at the outset
we do have access to all the answers
information is not the problem
Behavior change is the problem uh and
trying to figure out how to
merge the information with the behavior
change I I think is really key but it's
confusing for a lot of people right now
people get mixed messages about about
how to live and again you know it
requires because a lot of these
um modalities of modern living are
highly addictive like right you know
whether it's net Netflix or your phone
or processed food or the comfortable
chair at your house whatever it is like
it's hard to break
those habits because they've been
specifically designed to addict you
frankly so it's almost like not our
fault it's that the whole infrastructure
of our society is driving us towards
these behaviors that are making us
unhealthy and unhappy
design of society design a culture
design a community design a reality that
would be the antidote to all of the
problems that you just
so well laid out
yeah so you're going to ask me to solve
The World's problem that is a very
intense well you've talked more than 700
people you're really smart you're very
articulate you're very wise you've been
through a lot yourself yeah I mean I I
guess I would say I would say you know
first and foremost like
I'm not going to tell you that I have
the answers to all these problems nor am
I going to tell you that I've mastered
the routine that that uh you know takes
me out of the the Allure and the pull of
the world that we live in you're human I
do do a few things I mean I yeah like
I'm human and I'm on my phone too much
and I get short with my kids from time
to time and you know I like a good you
know Netflix crime show just like
everybody else so I watched Elmer I get
it you know okay right
um but I do you know have certain things
that I make sure that I do if not daily
as close to daily as possible and that
is a morning meditation practice a
journaling practice getting out in
nature every single day and I do that
through my endurance training whether
it's you know swimming cycling running
or or hiking or something like that like
I try to get Outdoors every single day I
sleep outdoors in a tent I don't know if
you know that about that but I actually
sleep I sleep outdoors and have for like
the last three or four years at this
point
um that's a whole other story that I can
tell you about but to kind of stay on
point
um you know I try to have rules around
the phone I try to make sure that I
carve out time for friendships no matter
how busy I am and that's something that
I haven't been historically great at and
I'm trying to do more and that kind of
leads into you know the the broader like
what would the society what would the
ideal Society look like for me
uh I think the answer to that is first
appreciating that we're not we're not
going to move backwards technologically
like the the technological innovation
curve is going to continue so accepting
that as a truth and a mutable reality
how can we live more meaningful lives
within that construct I think you know
if we could return to you know not to be
too hippy-dippy about it but if we could
live a more communal existence I think
that would solve a lot of our problems
like it really does take a village to
raise children to feel like you're part
of something bigger than yourself to
have you know Mutual shared
responsibilities for uh you know things
that you know a collective relies upon
like all of those things I think are
what make us human and living uh you
know on a cul-de-sac in a Suburban
neighborhood doesn't serve Us in that
regard and you know as a parent and as
somebody who has parents who are now
elderly and you know my my in you know
my my father-in-law who passed away like
we've all had experiences with with how
we treat our elders which I think is
abominable like it used to be they were
part of the community and they were
respected and these were the wise ones
that we counted upon to share their
experiences like that is not part of our
culture whatsoever we just Warehouse
them once they reach an age in which
they're no longer productive
coming-of-age Customs for young people
where they have to as a collective you
know endure certain uh Rites of Passage
as they become older is also a tradition
that historically has been part of what
it means to be human that's no longer
the case like a vision around the camp a
vision yeah some something you know like
now we have you know the only thing we
have now is like Boy Scouts Girl Scouts
and bar mitzvahs but you know the roots
of that the antecedent of those Rites of
Passage which have been you know
traditionally much more robust and
challenging and you know I think we
would be better off if every young
person had to enter some form of Public
Service After High School whether that's
military or Peace Corps or you know some
kind of uh collective experience that is
about service because I think you know
we're in a culture where we are we value
individualism and material gain and
status and and you know we're missing
the bigger picture which is how are we
all contributing to a greater whole and
I think that used to be part of the
American experience and now you know as
we've arrived at this splintered
fractured reality that we live in I
don't feel like we have any kind of
shared
principles that allow us to cohere as a
nation and I think a return to what
could really Bond us as a broader
culture would be something that young
people have to all do like some kind of
mandatory service I think would be
extremely beneficial
[Music]